hey on our phone now i asked him to call
in um
i wanted to talk to mad dog russo i was
sitting and thinking about him yesterday
with this whole radio hall of fame
i saw he was nominated again and i know
what happened last year last year he was
nominated
and then no one voted for him to be in
the radio hall of fame he didn't get
those people what's going on mad dog
that you good morning howard you've
always promised me that you will if i
ever do get in you will do the induction
speech
when did you do that howard i told you i
will not do the induction because i'm
not showing i don't care about radio
hall of fame although listen it's nice
to be included don't get me wrong i know
it's not important for you to do any and
we're getting ahead of ourselves you got
to win these stupid votes but i would
love
for you why don't you go out there and
you can even put it on tape do a little
induction ceremony for me i'll tell you
why i'll tell you why chris number one
i didn't show up for my own induction
into the radio hall of fame
as far as i know i don't even know if
there is a radio hall of fame anywhere
where do you go yeah we don't even know
where to go yeah i don't know where you
see this hall of fame but i can get your
directions on that robin way to go uh
and again we're we're way ahead of
ourselves you know how these votes go
who knows with these votes i mean one
day one year you think you make it next
year you think you make it you don't
make it either time you know your old
partner there and i don't knock the guy
he has a big career i get it but how
could he be in and you not be in what
would you do have sunny but not share
bert but not ernie it doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense
i love you howard do you think i'll get
into sure i cannot imagine that you
won't now i don't listen to sports shows
but i used to listen to mike and the mad
dog
on terrestrial radio and i wasn't there
for
for mike
it was
a dog that i listened to of course of
course well who who got his own channel
it's serious mad dog i do think there is
a little professional jealousy
it is a vote there's a lot of people on
there that you and i aren't that
familiar with that maybe some of the
voters
how badly do you want this on a scale of
one to ten ten means i must be in the
radio hall of fame one means i don't
give a [ __ ]
give me the number seven but i still
have no shot of you saying
uh welcome me into the hall of fame even
if you agreed we agreed the last time we
talked that you would ask david
letterman i thought that would be a good
guide i will i will do that i will do
that but you're going to have to help me
reach out to him if i don't get in
i'm not bothering him i i neither do i
i'm not bothering the man thank you
you think you'd do it no
i'm i'm just trying to get me out of
doing it that's all